I did say that I'm oversimplifying,
and there are a few other things.
So there are a few other bits
that can go with this other
information that we are talking about.
In particular, there's an interesting
thing called setuid, and
maybe we want to talk
about this a little bit.
Think about a game program that
needs to update a file that
stores the scores of different
people who have played this game.
So when these people are playing
the game, of course,
we want to be able to update that file.
When your score increases you want to
update your score that's in there.
So, these users while playing the game,
and they play the game,
need to have write access to that file.
When they're not playing the game,
we don't want them to have write access
because then they can go change
the score without playing the game, so
we don't want that.
So how can we solve this problem?
These systems I'm talking about,
this problem is solved by having
something called a setuid bit.
So the way to understand this
is that we have Alice and
Bob, and Bob owns the game file,
and Alice wants to play the game.
So the game file is actually owned by
Bob, and Bob is going to give permission
to Alice to execute,
being able to execute this file.
By the way, the score file is also,
Bob is going to own the score, and
is not going to grant write
access to Alice because
Alice should not be able to update that
file unless she's playing the game.
So you can think about the score file,
Alice can read it, her score and
somebody else's score, how people
are doing, but she can't write it.
Bob can rewrite it because Bob owns
the game file that we have here.
He's some special user, or someone who
is running this program that we have.
People who want to play the game.
So, setuid bit is set on the game file,
the executable file that we have.
And we said Alice executes this file
when she wants to play the game.
So setuid bit,
when it's set on executable file,
actually does an interesting thing.
When Alice executes this file,
the User ID temporarily
changes it from Alice to Bob.
So it says when a setuid file
is executed, the User ID,
effective User ID, at that point is not
the user who actually executed the file,
but is owner of this file.
In this case,
the owner of the file is Bob.
So during the execution of the game,
although Alice is playing the game,
during the execution of the game, the
temporary or effective UID is Bob, and
because of that,
even though Alice is playing the game,
she is able to update the file.
File is updated back that
is in this game file.
And while we're executing the game file,
as we said,
the effective User ID becomes Bob.
Alice launched this program, but
the program is owned by somebody else.
This change in UID is possible when
the executable file that Alice executes,
the game file here,
has a setuid bit set.
So a setuid bit is used to change the
UID temporarily during the execution of
the program on which this bit is set,
and I hope I motivated why you may want
to do that, in this case, for example,
the game file that we are talking about.